sens public continue c'est l'heure de
notre second débat consacré à cette
décision européenne de renouveler pour
10 ans l'autorisation du glyphosate
avant de débattre de sa dangerosité des
alternatives à ce pesticide on vous
dévoile qui a voté pour ou contre s'est
abstenu à la Commission européenne audre
beetaz la photo de famille européenne se
craquelle quand on prononce le mot
glyphosate ce pesticide peu cher ultra
efficace mais très controversé que
certains États-membres voudraient
interdire quand l'agriculture des autres
en dépend
déposition qui semble
irréconciliable 16 novembre 2023
l'autorisation du glyphosate arrive
bientôt à échéance sur ce dossier
particulier la Commission européenne a
la main en s'appuyant sur plusieurs
études elle propose une réautorisation
pour 10 ans accompagné de restrictions
interdiction d'utiliser le glyphosate
pour déshumidifier les cult est mise en
place de zones tampon pour valider ou
bloquer cette proposition les
États-membres doivent voter à la
majorité qualifié pour avoir une
majorité qualifiée il fallait que 15
pays européens valident le texte mais
pas seulement il fallait également que
les pays représentent au minimum 65 % de
la population européenne et donc à
l'issue de ces deux votes aucune
majorité n'a été trouvée donc le dernier
mot a été donc pour la Commission
européenne dans le détail seul trois
pays ont voté contre la Croatie
l'Autriche et le Luxembourg qui est le
premier pays à avoir tenté de bannir le
glyphosate sur son territoire en 2020 on
est à presque 80 % des agriculteurs qui
ont signé le programme pour rénoncer
volontairement au glyphosate ça monre
aussi que le besoin d'utiliser
glyphosate n'est pas si important au
Luxembourg dans le camp adverse ils sont
nombreux à défendre la molécule 17 pays
dont l'Espagne et le Portugal terre de
production intensive mais aussi les pays
d'Europe centrale le débat sur le
glyphosate n'est pas le même partout en
Europe euh et et très clairement la
sensibilité et le et le symbole qui est
devenu ce produit en France ou en
Allemagne ne ne l' pas si on prend
d'autres pays comme la Pologne la
Roumanie euh
ou la Grèce euh par exemple dans le 3e
camp il y a ceux qui se sont abstenus
comme l'Italie l'Allemagne ou la France
tirailler entre une opinion public
antiglyphosate et des agriculteurs qui
affirment ne pas pouvoir s'en passer la
France l'Allemagne et l'Italie n ont
préféré ne pas se prononcer parce qu'il
voulent à la fois réduire les produits
phytosanitaires mais sans les les
interdire radicalement car selon eux le
les agricultures nationales ne
pourraient pas se remettre d'une d'une
interdiction brutale des produits
phytosanitaires étant donné que pour eux
il n'y a pas encore d'alternative
efficace à cette molécule un imbroglio
de position qui mène donc a une
réautorisation du pesticide pour 10
années
supplémentaires la dangerosité et les
alternatives au glyphosate on en débat
avec Daniel salmon bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur écologie
solidarité et territoire d'î et Villen
tir Coué bonsoir et bienvenue président
de la frse la Fédération Régionale de
Bretagne et secrétaire général adjoint
de la FNSEA j'accueille également
Pierre-Marie Aubert bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes ingénieur agronome directeur
du programme agriculture à l'Institut de
développement durable et des relations
internationales et tranui évidemment est
resté à mes côtés éditorialiste pour
pour sens public euh Daniel salmon cette
décision européenne euh bah c'est un
échec pour ceux qui comme vous veulent
interdite le interdire le glyphosate
pourquoi les écologistes les
associations qui sont nombreuses n'ont
pas réussi à à convaincre finalement
suffisamment de gouvernement en Europe
pour
l'interdire tout simplement parce que on
est typiquement là dans la fabrique du
doute connu pour pour l'amante qu'on a
connu pour les fossiles qu'on a connu
pour le chlore d'écones où on a en face
de nous des lobbies puissants de la
chimie qui s'ingénie à payer des études
pour amener le doute auprès de la
population et auprès des différents
acteurs effectivement on a des
métaanalyses qui sont très claires sur
le glyphosate des milliers d'analyses
indépendantes qui montrent la
dangerosité du glyphosate et à côté de
ça et bien euh les ça s'appuie sur
quelques études qui c'est avéré on a vu
les Monsanto papers sont des études qui
sont en grande partie pipoté donc il y a
il y a un vrai sujet là de de démocratie
et de transparence alors on va
évidemment revenir il y a deux grands
chapitres he dans ce débat les questions
de dangerosité et puis les alternatives
justement thier Coué là-dessus j'imagine
que vous l'avez accueilli avec
soulagement cette décision
européenne soulagement vous savez nous
on se réjouit oui de rien du tout en la
matière parce queon en a quand même un
peu marre de ces débats là nous le
glyphosate il est dans le domaine public
voilà on fait confiance à la science la
science on est bien dans le cadre de
l'fsa l'fsa c'est un collectif de
scientifiqu qui a regardé l'ensemble
c'est sans doute l'une des molécules qui
a été le plus étudié pendant 50 ans hein
c'est une molécule qui a été autorisée
dans les années 70 si je ne m'abuse donc
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui euh voilà on
a on l'a tellement étudié parce qu'elle
a tellement été attaquée faut se
rappeler quand même qu'on attaquait
monsantau à cause de du de l'agent
orange qui avait été utilisé au Vietnam
et cetera et cetera bon on arrive vous
l'utilisez comment vous l'utilisez oui
et si oui comment avec quelle précaution
alors avec quelle précaution les
précautions euh de l'ensemble des
produits phytosanitaires qu'on utilise
c'estàdire qu'on se on met un masque et
on les utilise avec une cabine et cetera
bon on est on n'est pas fou non plus
quoi on essaie de se protéger et puis et
puis il y a pas plus de de d'accidents
en agriculture qu' y en a dans le grand
public et vous l'utilisez le moins
possible quand vous l'utilisez ou bien
vous qu'est-ce qu'on a intérêt à
utiliser un produit qui nous coûte donc
il faut l'utiliser à bon il coûte cher B
oui ça coûte donc ça veut dire qu'on a
aucun intérêt à à utiliser un produit
qui ne nous serait pas utile bon moi je
l'utilise ch que que le mécanique quand
même non j'utilise juste vous dire mon
exemple euh j'utilise pas de façon
intensive j'utilise pas sur mes cultures
j'utilise à 1 l5i à l'hectare sur 10000
m² voilà 1 L dem d'accord donc c'est pas
non plus une utilisation comme on peut
l'avoir par exemple aux États-Unis où là
effectivement on l'utilise sur les
cultures en France on l'utilise pas sur
les cultures on l'utilise uniquement
pour désherber des des Adventi enfin des
mauvaises herbes elle ça ou des herbes
concurrentes au cultures alors voilà ça
posait bien le le le le débat et
l'utilisation on reviendra sur les
alternatives Pierre Marie Aubert cette
décision c'est c'est d'abord le concept
d'une Europe qui est qui est très
divisée ça s'explique comment par le
poids de l'agriculture en fonction des
pays par justement cette fabrique du
tout en tout cas cette absence de
consensus scientifique non je pense
qu'effectivement dans les différents
pays d'Europe on est à des on a des
agricultures com prennent des formes
extrêmement différentes le projet de
l'agriculture polonaise ou l'agriculture
danoise n'est pas le projet de
l'agriculture française et aujourd'hui
néanmoins on est dans un marché commun
euh et donc ces projetsl quelque part
s'ils sont différents et s'il y a un
pays qui peut tirer son épagne du jeu il
va le faire euh donc je prends un
exemple qui est pas sur le glyphosate
mais qui va illustrer mon propos dans
les négociations sur la politique
agricole commune un pays comme la
Pologne va chercher à maximiser ce qu'on
appelle les paiements directs sur son
Pilion c'est-à-dire ce qui va permettre
de développer l'agriculture dite très
intensive et minimiser tout ce qui va
aller sur des mesures
agro-environnementales pour gagner en
compétitivité et pour accroître sa
production et gagner des pars de marché
le projet français il est un petit peu
différent le projet danois il est encore
très différent il va jouer sur d'autres
leviers et ça ça on le voit très bien en
fait à l'œuvre effectivement dans cette
question du glyphosate mais sur tout un
tas d'autres dossiers agricoles et je
rajouterai un point ici c'est que non
seulement on a une tension interne à
l'Europe qui se manifeste là sur le
glyphosate mais qui s'est manifesté sur
le pacte vert qui s'est manifesté sur la
réforme de la PAC mais on a aussi une
tension extrêmement forte entre l'Europe
et on va dire le reste des grands pays
agricoles que sont les États-Unis le
Canada la Nouvelle-Zélande et
l'Australie et donc quand l'Union
européenne en 2020 publie son pacte vert
et sa sa stratégie de la fourche à la
fourchette h avec une une vraie vision
on peut contester cette vision on peut
la discuter je pense que elle est très
intéressante à bien des égards peut-être
qu'on sera d'accord avec Thierry mais
c'est pas forcément le point ici et bien
la réponse immédiate des États-Unis
d'Amérique a été de faire un espèce de
contre farm tout fort en disant mais
regardez écoutez nous on va faire une
coalition pour le développement durable
de la productivité des ce que je veux
dire c'est que on a un marché commun en
interne mais on a aussi un marché
international et que du coup ces
tensions intra eururopéennes mais aussi
culturel on a une bataille culturelle
sur le système alimentaire qu'on veut et
bien elles sont très compliquées à gérer
pour le monde agricole en l'absence
d'une vision qui va porter les
transformations qu'on souhaite le
glyphosate est un bon exemple mais je
pense juste term làdessus qu'audelà du
glyphosate la question qu'on doit poser
c'est celle des phyos le glyphosate en
tant que molécule si je le dis de
manière abrupte on s'en fiche un petit
peu c'est l'usage c'est l'usage
DESAGE a dit le glyphose ça a été hyper
étudié finement c'est une molécule dont
la dangerosité environnementale
peut-être pas la plus importante il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à dire donc je
vous interromps la France on l'a dit
hein dans le le sujet d'ouverture d'audy
c'est abstenu voici comment le ministre
de l'Agriculture a justifié son choix
vous êtes pas contre totalement et que
vous n'êtes pas pour la proposition qui
est faite l'abstention c'est en fait ce
qu'on pense voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est c'est idiot he mais des fois c'est
bien de voter comme on pense qu'est-ce
qu'on pense qu'on a besoin de glyphosate
dans certains usages et qu'on pense
queon peut s'en passer dans d'autres bah
on s'abstient dans ces CASL tout cas
c'est comme ça que je fais la
politique Tam le le glyphosate c'est
l'un des sujets sur lequel Emmanuel
Macron a changé la vie oui virage à 180
retour en 2017 Emmanuel Macron a fait un
coup politique hein il a nommé Nicolas
hullo ministre de la transition
écologique il a lancé un slogan qu'il
fera consacré champion de la Terre ce
slogan c'est make our planet greatat
again qui est aussi le hashtag associé à
ce tweet j'ai demandé au gouvernement de
prendre les dispositions nécessaires
pour que l'utilisation du glyphosate
soit interdite en France au plus tard
dans 3 ans stupur tremble ement angoisse
dans les milieux agricoles mais voilà
comme souvent en politique c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire un an plus tard
en 2018 pas d'inscription de cette
interdiction dans la loi agriculture et
alimentation ça fait aussi partie des
raisons pour lesquelles Nicolas HULLOT
en a gros sur le cœur et démissionne
avec fracas en dénonçant la présence des
lobby dans les cercles du pouvoir
Emmanuel Macron va donc changer d'avis
sur cette question du glyphosate et oui
6 mois plus tard alors que les gilets
jaunes occupent les rond-points Emmanuel
Macron lui occupe nos écrans et le
terrain avec son grand et voilà sa
promesse de 2017 qui a droit à un
enterrement de première classe voilà ce
que dit le président de la République à
bourde péage en janvier 2019 peut-on
dire qu'il n'y aura plus de glyphosate
dans 3 ans c'est impossible je ne vais
pas vous mentir ce n'est pas vrai si je
vous disais ça je tue complètement
certaines filières le 6 janvier 2022
début de campagne pour le second mandat
Emmanuel Macron face au lecteur du
Parisien explique encore c'est l'erreur
que j'ai commise au début du quinquena
il faut agir sur ces sujets au niveau
européen cela ne marche pas si on le
fait tout seul voilà les premiers seront
les derniers étaler l'Évangile
d'Emmanuel Macron les premiers à sortir
du glyphosat risque bien d'être les
seuls et les derniers en compétitivité
voilà pour le raisonnement qui nous
aligne donc avec nos voisins européens
et alors si on file encore la
démonstration si on rentre un peu plus
dans le détail pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
qu'il a changé d'avis bah quand on
écoute Emmanuel Macron 2017 on croit
entendre Nicolas HULLOT quand on écoute
celui de 2019 c'est beaucoup plus proche
du message de la
FNSEA déjà en septembre 2017 la
présidente de la ade alors Christian
Lambert disait hors de question que si
l'Europe dit oui la France dise non non
donc aux distorsions de concurrence et
tous les ministres de l'Agriculture ont
ent tené ce refrain Stéphane Travert
Didier Guillaume Julien de Normandie
aujourd'hui ben on l'a compris Marc
fenau il y a même des passeril entre le
syndicat d'agriculteur Renaissance on
prend l'ancien président des g des
jeunes agriculteurs Jérémie de sererles
il est devenu député européen Ren le
message d'jourd'hui aux agriculteurs
c'est donc le glyphosate si vous pouvez
vous en passer vous le faites si vous ne
pouvez pas vous ne le faites pas alors
les agriculteurs ils ont tout de même
baissé leur consommation de glyphosate
de 25 % en 2022 les mauvaises langues
diront que c'est grâce à la sécheresse
sécheresse égale moins de mauvaise
herbes égale moins de glyphosate au
rythme où va le réchauffement on aura
bientôt plus besoin du tout de round up
de l'ironie bien sû on a bien compris
Daniel salmon est-ce qu'il y a
effectivement un risque pour la
compétitivité des agriculteurs français
si la France avait été la la la première
ou l'un des seuls pays d'Europe à à
renoncer au glyphosat vous le savez on a
eu un rapport en France au Sénat sur la
compétitivité de la ferme France alors
moi je mets en question ce mot
compétitivité qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
parce que il y a de la compétitivité qui
est qui se fait sur le bas coup le prix
le plus bas mais ce prix le plus bas il
est fait sans prendre en compte tout un
tas d'externalités négatives et les
pesticides ont un coût énorme pour la
société et si on les ajoutait au prix
qui est fait qui est donné sur le marché
tout de suite on serait beaucoup moins
compétitif pourquoi je parle de ça tout
simplement parce qu' il faut il faut
remettre le contexte si tout à est bien
moi je me poserai pas la question du
glyphosate ou des pesticides dans leur
dans leur ensemble mais qu'est-ce qu'on
a aujourd'hui on a un effondrement de la
fertilité humaine on a des cancers qui
augmentent on a un effondrement de la
biodiversité 70 % des masses d'insectes
ont disparu on a la Louette qui était
notre petit animal notre petit oiseau un
peu emblématique qui a pratiquement
disparu donc est-ce qu'on continue comme
ça parce que ce qu'on entend en
permanence quand même sur les plateaux
c'est vous allez trop vite oui et alors
qu'est-ce que l'on fait on a attend
encore 10 10 ans 20 ans qu'on soit dans
un désert pour agir donc non nous nous
pensons qu'il faut agir rapidement
effectivement il y a un problè est-ce
qu'il y avait un risque quand même parce
que si ça provoque la fermeture de de
dizaines ou de centaines d'exploitations
de sortir les premiers du du du
glyphosat c'est une question je pense
que la France elle a un rôle elle a un
rôle de locomotive pour l'Europe et donc
d'être le faire de lance de la
transition agroécologique et qu'il y a
un moment on pose des actes et quand on
s'est engagé en 2017 à sor dans les 300
et bien on essaie de tenir on fait pas
du rétropédalage en permanence
d'ailleurs comment voulez-vous que le
citoyen s'y retrouve on s'engage sur des
choses et au bout de quelques années on
dit que c'est plus possible fallait
réfléchir avant parce queon gagne pas
des élections on a simplement avec des
promesses moi je je veux des actes juste
une dernière chose dernière chose sur la
molécule le glyphosate la molécule la
plus étudiée effectivement on étudie la
molécule des glyphosate mais il y a des
compos
dans un pesticide des cormulant il y a
des impuretés il y a tout un tas de
choses qui ne sont pas étudié dans leur
ensemble et c'est ça qui fait la
différence entre les différentes études
c'està-dire si on utilise si on étudie
simplement une molécule et qu'on fait
des études comme ça en silo et bien on
ne voit pas l'effet cocktail et tout un
tas de choses qui se passent et qui sont
très dangereus on va y revenir sur la
dangerosité je voudrais vous entendre
sur la compétitivité quand même
imaginons qu'Emmanuel Macron ait tenu sa
promesse de 201 17 d'après vous
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé est-ce qui
se serait passé j'en sais rien est-ce
qu'il y aurait eu une perte de
compétitivité des exploitations
françaises par rapport aux concurrentes
européenes voilà on y est déjà puisque
nous on a une utilisation des produits
on a à peu près 400 400 50 produits en
France en Europe on est à peu près à
plus de 600 produits homologués de chez
nos voisins et dans le monde on est à
1500 produits homologués à peu près bien
ça veut dire que on est déjà nous on a
déjà éliminé les produits les plus
dangereux h il faut quand même le savoir
ça parce que on dit il faut quand même
bien regarder la notion de bénéfice
risque voilà et et cette notion là nous
on a quand même pas intérêt à utiliser
des produits super dangereux ou alors il
faut qu'on qu'on soit complètement
dément bon on est citoyen on est per de
famille mère de famille pourquoi on
irait faire des des choses comme ça donc
on le économique du cand en terme de
compétitivité alors en terme de
compétitivité évidemment qu'on a perdu
la preuve la ferme France aujourd'hui
diminue dans toutes ces productions les
productions horticoles les productions
arboricoles euh les les productions
animales les l'ensemble des productions
françaises chutent dans un contexte
européen qui lui était plutôt sur une
forme de stabilité mais avec une
tendance à la chute aussi donc ça veut
dire que dans le contexte européens on
va plus vite que nos collègues européens
en terme de chute mais dans le contexte
mondial on chute plus vite au niveau de
l'Europe que les autres pays voilà alors
est-ce que ça a du sens aujourd'hui par
exemple d'importer énormément d'autres
pays de produire moins chez nous et
d'importer des autres pays voilà est-ce
que écologiquement ça a du sens
économiquement on le sait la balance
commerciale s'écroule c'est ça aussi
ouais la chute de la compétitivité pour
la ferme France ou allez on va pas on va
on va ouvrir même si on a commencé à
l'évoquer un chapitre complet consacré à
la question de la dangerosité je
voudrais que Jonathan dupriz nous
rejoigne sur sur ce plateau puisque il a
compilé un certain nombre de
d'information et d'études rebonsoir
Jonathan alors on va commencer sur la
question des risques avérés pour la
santé humaine alors les risques avérés
il y a plusieurs études Thomas qui font
état de ces ses fameux risques celle
dont on parle le plus c'est celle de
2015 de l'OMS qui a classé le glyphosate
comme cancérogène probable selon
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé dont
l'étude provient de 1000 échantillons
scientifique dit indépendant il y aurait
des preuves certes limitées tempère
l'OMS mais preuve tout de même de risque
de développer un cancer du sang lors de
contact répété avec cette substance
présente dans les herbicides en 2021
l'incerme le le très sérieux institut de
recherche dénonce lui aussi un surrisque
je cite de développer des tumeurs
cancéreuses de la moelle et il y en a
beaucoup d'autres notamment une étude
américaine de 2019 qui conclu elle que
les travailleurs exposés au glyphosate
et bien il verraent le risque de cancer
de augmenter de 41 %. oui alors on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure ce qui sème le
doute c'est qu'il y a aussi beaucoup
d'études qui concluent à l'inverse qu'il
n'y a pas de danger avérés ouais
exactement et c'est à cause de de
l'absence d'uniformité des méthodologies
qui sont employées pour tester le le
glyphosate dans ces fameuses études et
c'est pour ça qu'on a un peu
l'impression que ces études elles disent
parfois un peu tout et leur et sont
contraire euh exemple la dernière en
date sur l'étude sur laquelle se base
l'Union européenne pour prolonger de 10
ans le l'expérience du du glyphosate
l'étude conclu je cite que l'évaluation
de l'impact du du glyphosate sur la
santé humaine la santé animale
l'environnement n'a pas identifié de
domaines de préoccupation critique ce
rapport c'est la compilation de 2400
expérience sur la santé humaine animale
et environnementale le FSA vente l'étude
je cite la plus comp te et la plus
transparente sur cet herbicide écoutez
ce qu'on disait la Commission
européenne notre proposition de
renouveler l'autorisation est basée sur
une évaluation massive approfondie par
l'EFSA par les États-membres par des
experts comme je l'ai expliqué à
plusieurs reprises donc nous nous
attendons pas à ce que les données
scientifiques vont changer demain parce
que EFSA et les collègues scientifiques
ont vraiment étudié tous les tous les
tous les études dans le domaine dans le
domaine et beaucoup voient cette
décision un retour en force et lobis
ouis absolument Thomas la décision de la
Commission européenne a provoqué la
colère de nombreux scientifiques de
nombreux spécialistes de la question je
vais vous citer une chercheuse de Line
Rae Laurence Huc cité dans un papier de
franceino qui dénonce par exemple une
fabrique du doute comparable à celle de
l'industrie du tabac qui n'hésite pas je
cite à produire des études truquées
écrites par les industriels qui sont
allés acheter des scientifiques en
résulte un vote plus idéologique que
scientifique pour certains eurodéputés
comme Pascal cfin
écoutezle il s'agit d'un travail
purement idéologique qui n'est pas fondé
sur la science ce qui aurait dû être
basé sur la science c'est une approche
plus équilibré plus prudente disant oui
il est réautorisé mais nous avons
introduit certaines restrictions qui
sont faites au niveau
européen et cette omniprésence des lobby
sur aier glyphosate c'est pas nouveau
c'est pas nouveau en 2017 il y a
l'affaire des Monsanto papers dont vous
vous souvenez peut-être c'est une
quantité de documents internes assez
énorme de la firme fabriquant le fameux
RUP le déserban que vous voyez
s'afficher ici c'est ces documents ils
sont révélés par la justice américaine
au grand public à l'occasion d'un procès
de plusieurs personnes qui sont
atteintes de de cancer et dans ces
révélations on apprend notamment que
face à la qualification dont je vous
parlais de cancérogène probable de l'OMS
et bien montsantau a mis en en œuvre une
véritable Guera procédurale he que c'est
c'est sans précédent dans cette
industrie pour brocarder je cite la
science pourrie de l'organisme onusien
donc c'était très violent même dans les
termes des armées d'avocats au trousse
des scientifiques des intimidations en
tout genre des pratiques que beaucoup
ont comparé finalement à une sorte de
mafia des des pesticides le tout pour
protéger bien sûr derrière une manne
financière que représente la vente de
glyphosate pour Bayer Montsanto
désormais des enjeux sont colossaux he
on estime que le le Roundup il rapporait
il rapporterait même si les chif sont
pas tout à fait confirmé par la firme
elle-même environ 5 milliards de dollars
par an ça fait environ 150 dollars à
chaque seconde merci beaucoup je attend
pour toutes ces informations je voudrais
alors évidemment vous êtes pas
toxicologue mais vous êtes ingénieur
agronome et donc votre voilà votre
conviction profonde sur la dangerosité
vous avez un peu répondu tout à l'heure
en disant attention il y a le glyphosate
d'un côté il y a les phyosanitaires dans
dans leur globalité c'est quoi votre
conviction bon moi ma conviction s'en
fiche un peu ce qui qui compte c'est ce
que nous dit la science et je pense que
Daniel salmon l'a bien dit tout à
l'heure au-delà du glyphosate je dire on
a on est sur un usage de phyo
aujourd'hui qui est principalement
responsable d'une chute de la
biodiversité sans précédent je rappelle
le dernier rapport de l'IPBES de 2019
qui nous dit la cause principale de la
perte de biodiversité sur la terre c'est
l'agriculture un par la déforestation de
par l'agriculture intensive donc on
détruit la biodiversité partout les
pesticides aujourd'hui vous allez
n'importe où sur terre vous en trouvez
he au-delà du point d'application vous
en avez partout sur Terre avec des
effets des TER un pesticide comme son
indique c'est fait pour tuer ou donc il
y a pas de débat un pesticide ça abîme
la biodiversité ça abîme les cours d'eau
et CEA c'est fait pour ça et y compris
la santé humaine y compris la santé
humaine c'est là où c'est moins mon
terrain de prédilection donc je vais pas
m'avancer là-dessus je voulais
simplement redire ce qu'a dit Daniel
salmont parce que c'est très important
le débat sur la dangerosité pour la
santé humaine du glyphosate et de la
plupart des pesticides il est en grande
partie lié et c'est un faux débat à
est-ce qu'on évalue la molécule où
est-ce qu'on émalue le produit dans son
ensemble il y a aucun agriculteur
peut-être Thierry toi qui met du
glyphosate tout seul on met du
roundoundup donc si on met du Roundup il
faut évaluer la dangerosité de
l'ensemble du produit y compris ces
cormulants et les métabolites qui sont
issus de la dégradation du produit dans
dans l'environnement donc ça c'est ça
qui est fondamental donc si moi je
m'entiens à ce que me raconte la science
les travaux scientifiques sur lesquels
je base mon travail il y a pas de
discussion sur l'ambition la réduction
des phyos de 50 % vous voir au-delà elle
est nécessaire pour reconquérir une
diversité végétale animale qui est le
seul garant de la productivité de long
terme des agrosystèmes ouis voulez
intervenir juste un petit
correctif de de ce que dit
pierremarie l'EFSA évalue la molécule
glyphosa donc l'sa c'est quoi d'ailleurs
parce qu'on l' cité deux fois ben voilà
c'est à vous de vous vous renseigner
mais l'fsa c'est un collectif de
scientif de tous les pays d'Europe qui
homologue les les produits alors il y a
il y a les cas aussi
ENF et donc c'est là-dessus que la
Commission s'appuie pour dire après tout
on peut prolonger vous vous dites
vousave on y reviendra pas Mo il y a
même je termine just qui termine
l'évaluation d'une molécule ensuite l'
en France qui est un collectif aussi de
recherche et sitifique évalue elle les
produits avec les mélanges et les met
évalue leur dangerosité pour la
biodiversité leur la la notion de
bénéfice risque et la dose auquel le
produit doit être utilisé et délivre une
AMM une autorisation de mise sur le
marché et ensuite nous donne le droit
pour telle utilisation sur
telle culture ou telle utilisation voà
par exemple pour le glyphosate pour en
interculture sur des des des
utilisations bien particulière
d'utiliser ce produitl donc vous dites
vous dites on est en confiance quand on
l'utilise mais oui lorsque non mais
c'est c'est une vraie question on va on
va tout comme bien d'autres produits que
vous utilisez dans votre maison les
lessives le le savon le la bombe pour
mais si c'est tout ça est évalué au
niveau de l' alors
d'accord votre avis vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est pipoté pourquoi vous allez
jusque là parce que c'est Guillem de 16
qui est un directeur de la prévention
des risques à l'EFSA qui dit lui-même il
dit pas que c'est pipoté mais il dit il
y a plein de biais de méthodologie dans
ce que l'on a sorti comme étude donc si
même l'fsa le dit on peut être
qu'inquiet parce que je vous le dis il y
a des m métaanalyses et les métaanalyses
c'est
une un rassemblement de tout un tas
d'analyse indépendante dans le monde qui
qui le montre très clairement donc pour
parler des agriculteurs effectivement
les agriculteurs ne sont qu'un rouage
dans une grosse machine qui va du
semencier a fabricant de phytosanitair
d'engrais et de l'agroalimentaire
derrière il n'est qu'un rouage et c'est
lui qui paye le prix cher c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire il enfin des des
maladie lié au au phyosanitaire il y en
a quelquesunes il y a pas très longtemps
j'étais pas très loin de vilain à Campel
à l'assemblée générale des collectifs
des victimes de pesticides qui sont des
agriculteurs conventionnelles et qui
développent Parkinson ezemer lymphome
cancer de la prostate qui sont des
maladies reconnues professionnelles donc
il y a un lien très net entre les
pesticides et donc ces maladies
professionnelles mais bon il y a
l'agriculteur qui est en première ligne
H on fait là aussi il y a une vraie
problématique avec les équipements de
protection individuelle les EPI H qui
dans la majorité des cas ne sont pas
bien employés et qui sont là pour faire
reposer la responsabilité sur
l'agriculteur si vous êtes malade c'est
parce que vous n'avez pas bien mis votre
EPI et vous n'avez pas bien lu toutes
les petites lignes vous voyez bien qui
sont sur le bidon qui font que le
produit ne serait jamais utilisé si on
devait appliquer pratiquement tout cela
donc ça c'est pour faire retomber la
responsabilité sur l'agriculteur c'est
lui qui prend le plus cher thier il y a
eu effectivement il y a eu des
procédures il y a il y a un agriculteur
qui s'appelle Paul François qui a
attaqué monsantant en justice qui a fini
par gagner ça je sais plus combien c'est
presque une décennie de de de procédure
justement sur la question du défaut
d'information comment vous réagissez à
ça vous mais est-ce que oui ou non euh
parce que vous dites je suis en
confiance c'est pour ça que je posais la
question tout à l'heure mais mais tous
vos collègues sont pas forcément dans le
même état d'esprit vous voyez ce que je
veux dire non non non et puis euh la
quand on dit l'industrie du doute
l'industrie du doute va dans les deux
sens évidemment qu'on il faut il faut
faire attention alors les les petites
allégations oui effectivement si vous
lisiez tout ce qui est mais c'est comme
lorsque vous prenez un flacon
d'antibiotique si vous lisez l'ensemble
des allégations qu'il y a dessus mais
alors vous arrêtez tout de suite vous n
allez pas prendre l'antibiotique mais
pourquoi vous prenez l'antibiotique il y
a bien une raison oui voilà et ben c'est
exactement la même chose vous revenez au
bénéfice risque dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure voilà c'est-à-dire que on doit
on doit bien mesurer mais estce qu'il
alors
pour vre votre trava so plus efface plus
productif vous demande moins de temps
pour retirer des mauvaises herbes je
suis pas agriculteur je dis ça avec mes
Mo moi mais que vous mettez en votre
danger en santé pardon il y a peut-être
un bénéfice pour l'exploitation mais un
risque pour l'agriculteur mais vous
croyez en responsabilité que je vais
prendre un risque pour ma santé comme ça
quand j'entends maladie par reconnu
maladie
professionnelle ça veut dire aussi que
nous au travers de notre métier on a une
homologation pour utiliser les produits
donc oui effectivement on peut dire mais
ils font ça ils font n'importe
quoi fait pas
noress d'utiliser les produits le mieux
que enfin comme ils doivent être
utiliser c'est du bon sens quoi donc à
un moment donné soit on l'utilise dans
dans les règles qu'il faut pour utiliser
ce produit comme la chez vous vous vous
la buvez pas tous les matins et cetera
bon voilà et bien là c'est pareil on ne
doit pas boire du glyphosate pur voilà
bah oui ça semble évident oui je pense
que
personne ne bois du glyphosate pur bon
bref l'argument un peu particulier Mar
sur cette notion de bénéfice risque
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez oui je pense que toute la
discussion qu'on est en train d'avoir
moi elle me pose un petit peu problème
je pense c'est pas forcément la bonne
discussion allezy
on est en train de se demander si c'est
vraiment possible de s'en passer si le
bénéfice risque c'est le bon et cetera
bon faut qu'on arrête de négocier
l'ambition l'ambition elle est pas
discutable la perte de biodiversité les
contraintes du changement climatique
qu'on a géré font qu'on n pas à négocier
l'ambition il faut se passer des
phytosanitaires c'est ce que vous nous
dites sauf qu'il faut s'en donner les
moyens question la question c'est le
comment et sur le comment là où moi je
rejoins la FD et plein de discussions
qu'on peut avoir extrêmement
constructive avec le monde agricole
c'est qu'on n pas de vision et qu'on a
arrive pas à poser la question du
comment là où parfois je vais être un
peu en en colère avec mes collègues
syndicalistes c'est quand on nous dit le
problème c'est qu'on n pas harmonisé au
niveau européen sur les phitos et sur
d'autres trucs et que dans le même temps
c'est mêmees colleèges syndicalistes il
passe aussi beaucoup de temps au niveau
de Bruxelles à faire en sorte que
l'harmonisation européenne ne se fasse
pas que ça bouge Paso voilà mais ce que
je veux dire juste pour dire sur la
question de l'ambition et sur les
questions des moyens la question des
moyens c'est une question de condition
de marché je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que disa monsieur
monsieur salmon tout à l'heure la
question de la compétitivité elle se
pose à n'importe quel opérateur
économique on peut pas faire l'impasse
dessus et donc la question c'est comment
on construit ensemble les conditions de
marché qui font
que les modèles d'agriculture les modes
de production qu'on veut voir se
développer il puisse se développer dans
des bonnes conditions pour l'agriculteur
pour le consommateur pour l'industrie
allez un mot de réponse Daniel oui tout
à fait non mais la compétitivité
effectivement elle est là dans notre
monde après à nous de l'organiser c'est
pas en signant tout les 4 matins des
traités de libre échange que ça va
s'arranger on met en compétition en
concurrence déloyale les agriculteurs du
monde entier et à force de faire des
guerres commercial on fait des guerres
tout courts et c'est ça la problématique
aujourd'hui effectivement moi j'entends
les ministres les un après les autres
qui me parlent des clauses miroir mais
on les voit jamais ces clauses miroir
les closes miroir ben c'est de faire en
sorte que un
produit importer quelque un produit
agricole qui a eu des qui a subi des
pesticides X ou Y si elles sont
interdite chez nous et bien on ne
l'importe pas ça c'est la clause miroir
on ne on n'importe pas des choses qui
seraient interdites chez nous et ça on
les voit pas du tout arriver donc il y a
un moment il va falloir réguler ça parce
que sinon là aussi c'est encore
l'agriculteur qui paye au bout du compte
le le prix fort alors il nous on a parlé
de la dangerosité longuement on va se
poser la question des alternatives
argument important principal peut-être
des agriculteurs pour justifier le le
prolonger l'usage tiens je vous propose
un extrait de documentaire documentaire
intitulé La Bosse le glyphosate et moi
c'est un film camera one télévision
d'Isabelle veryron on est dans un
échange entre la journaliste et un
agriculteur toi en tant qu'agriculteur
est-ce que tu as eu des aides pour
savoir comment tu allais pouvoir te
passer du glyphosate non aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas je nai je n'ai rien eu j'ai pas
eu d'aide ou de formation ou de de
choses qui puiss dire bon bah Bertrand
tiens fais autrement essaye autrement
pourtant toi tu es président de la FDSEA
qui est donc la fédération
départementale du syndicat majoritaire
de la FNA tu es bien placé pour savoir
s'il y a des aides mais ça veut dire
qu'aucun agriculteur n'a été accompagné
pour ce changement ah non non non
aujourd'hui il y a aucun ACC il y a
aucun accompagnement j'irai en en en
culture raisonnée pour dire bah voilà
vous arrêtez le glyphosate mettez alors
il y a des solutions pour pour pour
mettre en place hein ce que je vous
disais le le faux SMI mais mais c'est on
narrive pas au même résultat que quand
on utilise de temps en temps je dis bien
de temps en temps glyphosate ici en
grande culture qu'est-ce qu'on peut
inventer alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
inventer
oh bah un glyphosat bis voilà on va
inventer un glyphosat bis c'est assez il
est désabusé je je vous explique juste
le tutoimement entre la journaliste et
et l'agriculteur en fait c'est c'est sa
voisine et donc le principe de son
documentaire c'est je veux savoir
comment ça se passe autour de de chez
moi je vais rencontrer les les uns et
les autres on va être très concret ti si
vous utilisez pas de de allez on je vais
sortir du du glyphosate mais peut-être
de phytosanitaire d'abord est-ce que
c'est possible vous dites il y a pas
d'alternative ou alors c'est des heures
et des heures et des heures de travail
en plus mais le problème c'est ça alors
en agriculture on est confronté à des
injonctions contradictoires ou inutile
de vous dire qu'aujourd'hui on il faut
capter le carbone bien donc quand on dit
il faut capter le carbone il faut
essayer d'éviter d'utiliser du carburant
fossile bon la grosse consommation du
carburant fossile pour un tracteur c'est
le labour voilà parce que ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie donc pour remplacer
le labour on essaie de ne pas labourer
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut des herbé
autrement la culture qu'on va mettre en
place et va jamais pouvoir s'épanouir
voilà donc on utilise du glyphosate
justement pour éviter euh de manger du
carburant fossile voilà et bien 2 % de
la SAU en grande culture hericultà
pardon al c'est trop technique de la SAU
de la sur c'est 2 % de la surface
agricole en grande cultureà merci c'est
l'une des solutions oui oui mais c'est 2
% donc c'est pas la voilà mais j'ai pas
dit que c'était la majorité je dis que
c'est une des solutions justement pour
décarbon com font ce qui s'en passe mais
comment font ce qui s'en passe ils
essaient d'augmenter les rotations mais
aussi ça veut dire du désherbage
mécanique quelque part et à certains
moment et donc ça oblige là encore à
repasser et et donc c'est plus de temps
aujourd'hui qui rêve de déerber à la
main vous non B voilà moi je suis déjà
pas
jardin là aussi il faut quand même qu'on
se pose les questions juste pour
développer sur ce que dit thier cou
parce que c'est extrêmement important
euh moi si je suis agriculteur
aujourd'hui et si pour des raisons X ou
Y j'ai héritaé d'une ferme en
conventionnelle il y a des chances que
j'utilise du glyphosate soyons clair
pourquoi parce que si je veux des si je
veux une parc si je veux nettoyer ma
parcelle comme on dit euh en fait il
faut que je fasse un chanre une Luserne
un truc voilà donc ça c'est la rotation
don qui va casser ma rotation
aujourd'hui elle est où la chanrière qui
va acheter ma camelotte si je fais un
chanre pendant 2 ans pour nettoyer ma
parcelle elle y est pas pourquoi
saint-gbin il fait pas du panneau de
chambre pour faire l'isolation zéro
carbone et donc donc on revient à ce
système finalement agroalimentaire qu'il
faut revoir en exement ete juste un
micro truc dans les points qui sont
compliqués et on va pas se se raconter
l'histoire dans les points qui sont
compliqués sur les phyos en général il y
a une question de de de biomasse totale
qu'on sort du champ oui donc quand en
gros on met moins de phyo aujourd'hui vu
l'état de la recherche sur ce qu'on va
appeler les espèces orphelines on va
réduire la biomasse totale qu'on sort du
champ donc on va être moins efficace on
va être moins productif en terme de
biomasse et dans le contexte qui est le
nôtre où entre 60 et 70 % de la biomasse
qui sort des champs elle part dans log
des animaux tant qu'on a autant de
production animal et de consommation de
produits animaux et surtout consommation
de produit animaux c'est très difficile
et on revient sur le modèle global
ok j'entends cet argument est-ce que le
problème c'est pas aussi quand même le
le consommateur qui est extrêmement
schizophrène et bien sûr on le sait hein
le glyphosate c'est un grand totem
personne n'est pour au niveau de
l'opinion publique et on voit bah
aujourd'hui l'effondrement par exemple
de la consommation du bio beaucoup de
d'agriculteurs qui se sont convertis et
qui ont des difficultés aujourd'hui
c'est pas aussi ça le sujet ah qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en 1980 on avit 1,7
million d'agriculteurs aujourd'hui on en
a 430000 est-ce que c'est un succès non
clairement et ça vient en éco à ce que
vous dites c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
il faut aller vite on n pas de temps à
perdre on est dans le rendement et donc
à un moment effectivement l'agriculteur
s'y retrouve plus parce que il y a une
question du Juste Prix l'agriculteur
n'est pas rémunéré à la hauteur de ses
produits le produit agricole ça a été
toujours la la variable d'ajustement
dans notre panier je dis le panier du
ménager histoire de pas dire la ménagère
c'est la variable d'ajustement donc on
paye de moins en moins pour acheter
d'autres produits et il y a moment il va
falloir revoir ça parce que la
nourriture c'est notre énergie à nous à
l'instant c'est parfaitement juste
malheureusement on peut le regretter
mais le bio est en train de prendre un
bouillon donc on pourra faire une autre
émission là-dessus parce que en 2
minutes ça va pas être facile mais tout
ça est parfaitement orchestré là aussi
moi je suis pas un complotiste mais on a
quand même mis en place tout un tas de
choses pour faire en sorte que ce marché
s'effondre avec la HVE avec le flou
qu'on a institué auprès du consommateur
havaleur environnemental là on a arrêté
le maintien à l'agriculture bio et en
fin de compte on a donc vous dites quoi
vous dites on parlait avec Pierre-Marie
Aubert de de l'absence de vrais virage
stratégique pour changer en profondeur
le système agroalimentaire ça a pas été
ça a pas été
fait va laerement terminer et ensuite je
donne la parole clairement clairement il
y a des alternatives on était là-dessus
les alternatives il y a des charru des
chômeuses il y a des des rouleaux
écraseurs il y a d'autres manières de
faire et d'ailleurs l'agriculture bio
est un bon exemple puisquon on y arrive
effectivement on y arrive dans d'autres
considérations c'est-à-dire il faut
accepter une certaine baisse du
rendement et encore pas partout mais ça
ça je rebondis et j'arrêterai là sur le
fait qu'aujourd'hui les 2 tiers de la
surface agricole en France servent à
l'alimentation animale et à un moment
c'est des régimes alimentaires qu'il
faut faire évoluer il faut avancer sur
ces deux pieds oui vouliez réagir bah
oui parce que moi je veux bien qu'on
parle de complotisme à chaque fois mais
enfin ça suffit là oui il y a une
responsabilité une dissociation entre le
citoyen et le consommateur bon et très
net enfin vous le constatez-vous aussi
là les signes de qualité on s'était
engagé hein la profession a progressé
hein en terme de bio en sur en terme de
surface bio que l'on a fait que l'on a
fait aujourd'hui les hectares de blé le
blé qui en bio c'est à peu près trois
fois moins de rendement entre deux les
bonnes années et trois ou quatre fois
moins les mauvaises années parce que
c'est quand même ça puisqu'on a plus la
régularité que l'on a puisqu'on se passe
d'outils nous permett PL aux exploitants
qui qui sont
passés ça arrive tout simplement que
c'est dans une
coopérative la coopérative s'engage
souvent à payer par exemple pour un
producteur laitier à payer le lait au
même prix ou limiter la baisse du prix
en bio et c'est le le les agriculteurs
conventionnels qui supportent euh le le
le différentiel juste pour comprendre la
coopérative continue d'acheter le lait
bio au prix du bio même s'il est entre
guillemets déclassé parce qu'il y a plus
de demande quoi c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer Heou c'est ça donc là
ça veut dire qu'ils assurent le débouché
en blé aujourd'hui un blé bio est
quasiment au même prix qu'un blé
conventionnel c'est complètement anormal
mais ça veut dire que derrière les
débouchés ne sont pas là donc ça veut
dire qu'on a forcé le marché ça veut
dire que le consommateur ne répond pas
au marché et on voit un écroulement des
signes de qualité alors que les
agriculteurs se sont engagés massivement
sur ces marchés aujourd'hui alors moi je
veux bien qu'on parle de complot mais il
est où le complot quoi à un moment donné
il y a un acheteur en face il est là il
est en face de vous glyphosate avec des
lobbies qui sont derrière très
clairement après il y a une question il
y a une question consommateur qui
empêche le consommateur
d'acheter tu un flou comme cela ou h
haute valeur environnementale moi j'en
ai discuté avec plein de personnes ils
se disent haute valeur environnementale
ah mais c'est encore meilleur que le bio
et donc effectivement il y a un moment
le consommateur il faut l'éclairer et il
ne faut pas
l'enfumer je pense que tout le monde a
pu avoir la parole merci beaucoup ça
prouve que le débat était passionnant
merci à tous d'y avoir participé je vous
dis à lundi pour un nouveau numéro de
sens publ notez que depuis ce soir c'est
tout nouveau on est également disponible
en podcast sur Youtube et puis vous
pouvez évidemment aller sur le site la
plateform
publsenat.fr note également que demain
dans la matinale Orian Mancini reçoit
Jérôme Fourquet politologue directeur du
département Opinion et stratégie
d'entreprise de l'Ifop belle soirée à
toutes et à tous
[Musique]
merci